hi I'm Greg Elbe I'm Ken Alvarado
welcome to the real rejects Channel top
5 announce 5 things you should never
search on Google from our last video
Greg Allen Colorado because you won't
find anything you have to do the nd
let's see what these people say you
should never search Google is considered
by many to be the best way to obtain new
information without doing anything
oh there are some things in this world
that are better off not being searched
on the internet their warning this video
is about to get pretty distant why
forget five terms which is regular
mobile number five Harlequin serious
Harlequin ichthyosis is a severe genetic
disorder that mainly affects the skin
infants with this condition are born
very hard crusty skin covering most of
their body in the world the skin forms
large diamond plates that are separated
by deep cracks or fissures the skin
abnormalities affect the shape of the
eyelids nose mouth and ears while
limiting a movement of the arms and legs
which is difficult to chest can lead to
breathing difficulties and even
respiratory failings the skin typically
forms a protective barrier between the
body and its surrounding environment
how are you skin abnormalities
associated with Harlequin ichthyosis
destroy this barrier making it difficult
for affected infants to control water
loss regulate body temperature and fight
infections infants with Harlequin
ichthyosis often experience excessive
dehydration and risk developing
life-threatening infections in the first
few weeks why can't we do believe is
rare for effective infants to survive
well once you have another person
symptom a medical care and treatment
it's now common for those affected by
this condition to live into their
childhood years or even adolescence this
condition is inherent in what is called
an autosomal recessive pattern which
essentially means both copies of the
gene in each cell has mutations the
parents of an individual with an
autosomal recessive condition each carry
one copy of the mutated gene but it
usually never show signs or symptoms of
the condition number four is family yes
Brian pepper spells online back in 2005
with many believing at least some sort
of footage
however when peppers is in fact a real
person
Brian suffers from an abnormality known
as a blurred sensor which will cause
some rather disturbing facial injuries
this photo of bride was taken from an
Ohio sex offender database that states
that Brian was arrested back in 1998 for
gross sexual imposition which is defined
in Ohio as unwilling sexual contact with
one who is not one spouse he was
sentenced to 30 days in jail for this
with another 5 years probation so having
that Brian's had ways that hang 2012 but
it's clear that his memory will live on
as an internet meme for years to come
number 3 alvaro infection a [ __ ] is
also known as a [ __ ] a jiggle or sand
for you these small pen sized bottles
are usually found in sandy terrain of
warm dry climates they prefer deserts
beaches stables or farms they typically
hiding crevices and small cracks that
can be found on floors walls or even
some furniture commonly feeding on
warm-blooded hosts including humans cats
dogs rats pigs cattle and sheep a female
chitter feeds by burrowing into the skin
of a toast after finding this new home
the bugs abdomen greatly increases in
size until it flows around sac mimicking
the shape and size of a pea and
impregnated since we usually embeds
itself in skin under the toenails and
fingernails of humans or sores formic
filled with pots often becoming infected
I think I've had evidence of an
infestation by saying fleas a tiny black
dog yeah
because this bugs may not even have
enough most sites of infestation occur
on the feet often on the soles or other
two names within the next few weeks this
small black dot will slowly enlarge into
a white pea-sized bubble which is often
excruciating pain severe infestations
may result in a cluster of bubbles
giving a honeycomb appearance some
infestations calm to severe inflammation
lots of toenails amputation of the
affected area or even death due to
infection the survivors can
that's how about to give me more
affection which may also result in death
or if you manage to survive most tears
will die off
what's already advocated usually heels
now the worst one blatant one I saw
aired in Kokomo mag nota is a Canadian
murder convicted of killing and
dismembering Lin Jun a Chinese student
the male Asians hands and feet two
elementary schools and federal political
party offices after a video depicting
the murder was posted online in May of
2012 not known a flat Canada prompting
an Interpol red walls in an
international manhunt he was apprehended
at an internet cafe in Berlin already
news about himself in June of 2012 why
their case we sought by enormous groups
directly uploading videos of himself
killing hidden oh you know was murdered
by that Noda was a student from mulan
and an undergraduate in engineering and
computer science faculty at concordia
university he worked part-time as a
convenience store clerk in quote st.
John's and have been studying the
montreal since July of 2011 we moved
into a Griffin town area apartment with
his roommate in May of that senior he
was last seen on may 24th 2012 and its
fringe reported receiving a final text
message tournament 9 p.m. his boss then
became suspicious when he didn't show up
for its shipment three of his friends
went to his apartment on may 27th but he
wasn't there he was reported missing to
police two days later on May 25th 2012
an 11 minute video titled one lunatic
one ice pick was uploaded to best Goren
comm depicting a naked male tied to a
bed frame being repeatedly stabbed with
an ice pick and a kitchen knife then
being dismembered followed by acts of
necrophilia the perpetrator uses a knife
and fork to cost the man's flesh and
gets a dog to chew on the body
throughout the video in 1975 new order
song true faith plays in the background
and a holster for the 1942 film
Casablanca is visible on the wall
Canadian authorities obtained a more
extensive version of the video and said
cannibalism may have also been performed
materials promoting the video appeared
online ten days before the murder took
place on May 26 an attorney from Montana
attempted to report the video to Toronto
police is local sheriff and FBI but the
report was dismissed by officials police
later confirmed the video was authentic
and
by the victim as the same one whose body
parts were mailed to Ottawa 11:00 a.m.
on May 29 2012 a package containing a
left foot was delivered to the National
Headquarters of the Conservative Party
of Tanana the package was stained with
blood a foul smell was marked with a red
heart symbol another package containing
ability intercepted in a corner post
processing facility addressed to the
Liberal Party a janitor then discovered
a decomposing torso inside of a suitcase
left a library file in an alley behind
an apartment building in the Snowden
area of Montreal after searching the
scene of the crime police recovered
human remains bloody clothes papers
identified with suspect as well as sharp
and blunt objects from the back out
footage from surveillance cameras inside
the building showed a suspect bringing
multiple garbage bags outside and the
images match the suspect who was
captured on video of the local post
office police then searched the
apartment that i've noted was renting it
moved in four months prior and his rent
was paid up until June 1st the apartment
had been mostly empty before he left but
blood was found on different items
putting the mattress refrigerator the
table and the bathtub if you don't like
the reflection don't look in the mirror
was written in red ink inside of a
closet a note was later found in a
package sent to the conservative
verityjames 6 body parts have been
distributed and the perpetrator would
kill again
the other three packages also contain
notes but their contents are undisclosed
when recited on terms about possible
gamma cannon rods on June 5th 2012 the
package containing a right foot was
delivered to st. George's School in
another package containing the right
hand to false Creek Elementary School in
Vancouver both schools opened a thermal
the following morning it was confirmed
that both packages were sent from
Montreal on June 13 the additional limbs
and the torso were matched to rent isn't
DNA samples from his family are July 1st
when Ted was recovered at the edge of a
small lake in Montreal after police
received an anonymous tip Lin's body was
been cremated on July 11 and his ashes
were buried on July 26 at Miller down
Cemetery in Montreal these dates are
really important number one why food
makes a lot of us they deserve to
preface a bit why food basically means
wife and Japanese that's really all the
information you need for this video
what
brace yourselves it's going to get weird
as this video begins we see a woman
knocking on a man's door severe demand
then answers the door and the typical
over-the-top Japanese television catch
as a narrator explains what it means to
be a great spouse the video continues to
cook a meal of chicken stir-fry day and
to then take them all to a dining room
where it seemed as though they're going
to consume the food though things go
downhill rather cool the woman then wins
over the third if she's going to take a
lot but then aggressively vomits into
the bowl numerous times the man rather
disturbingly seems to enjoy the couple
that makes their way to the couch where
she continues to vomit profuse often
spilling chunks directly into his open
mouth I'll see you guys later after this
I need to take a break for me internet
for a while thank you guys so much for
watching
well it's not number one is not the
murder cookies I think because we've
heard more of murder stuff then that one
is just grabbing the thought of like
even just you Bobby
my mouth makes me wanna vomit this is a
Otters
bobbing back in four three two girls one
cup yeah see that's not the you
shouldn't search on Google right I don't
know about like a bug in the whole of
kid avid into for me she was going to
grow as like one egg tonight and I'm
thinking about my own tree having like
bubbles of bugs like on the inside
beginning to like bubble up then having
like my feed just like explode and like
bugs just come out like that was pretty
disturbing you know what I mean that's
informative yeah but my fingers are all
we're thinking about it that's like like
something keeps okay to Google like
let's say you have something going on I
should Google that you should google it
and find out the answer yeah I was told
not to Google this I don't think I
should take any measures to prevent
something worse about you
even the look when a ketosis I think
that's how you say it
Oh aren't you smart and more than just
jokes you have a lot of potential here
at the school should we should set up
any more than a class clown you can have
a high academia I know yeah I mean I
kind of want to see what one of these
kids looks like I don't want to see it
in person to sunset I don't know about
in person you know I don't want to like
you right if I'm one of you come with
the cone Harlequin it's a serious whoa
like run
whoa aah
oh why why having okay maybe you
shouldn't Google this I'm sorry did
everyone Anna sorry
lobby not gonna funny on my girl Oh
Bobby I feel I feel back boobs hard yeah
- everyone was Harlech when it ketosis
or know somebody was related to somebody
or it's had a child with that we're
hearts go out to you yes the second one
was the oh that guy yeah what's it
what's Ryan pepper how you endure all
these things it's like you pay attention
Brian peppers holy crap I got to do the
exact opposite was a bully crap now this
poor guy became a meme that socks it's
not his fault he was born that's just
mean
I think I would I would be friends with
him
can we can we take a second and just
point out that he got charged with
unlawful contact with someone who was
not his spouse or unwanted unlawful
contact with someone with life which
really implies that spousal rape is okay
in that state not cool yeah we're if
they're with you cat I'm right there
with you I got your back on that thang
I would totally pay attention to
everything you said spousal ripped and
it's not like you were against it so I'm
right there backing her point I was not
engrossed by the photos of Brian peppers
but I don't want to make fun of him I
mean with so many people have already
well yes for we shouldn't know
man let's just move on we're gonna don't
speak ill of the dead lisaknott I was he
dead
unless it's Hitler yeah okay the reason
well yeah [ __ ] about him
penis littlest one that's why did
everything
dude this sports story is okay we got a
comment about that
this guy's took some extreme measures I
there was so much going on in that one
story I don't even think I fully grasped
everything that he was doing everything
that's like a bad thing that be done was
done in this there isn't stabbing there
is my time perception I just stabbing to
knife
Andy icepick and eating there was a fork
ball feeding the the flesh to the dog be
a dog kind of hacking up the body
sending it to elementary country school
politician and on top of it necrophilia
you chose you I felt really
uncomfortable listening to this lunch so
I know it's not ideally so happy cats
here sure she doesn't regret driving all
the way out here today
pick a late night trip I get to go to
bed tonight yeah you go to bed at night
alone no no I think I'm not a Harlequin
I cry backers copycat nice pic days and
also imagining me vomiting into your
mouth because I'm laughing at you you
know what I don't want to be comic in me
is like oh my God if I can make somebody
laugh away bonded let me crush I would
make the news right there like a reflex
but anyone has that ever happen to
anyone
oh why are so hard I'm vomited sometimes
I walk towards white people accessing
sometimes I laugh - I almost peed on pee
I almost do I laugh to my [ __ ] on
average then I a heckled by the stand-up
comic we shared our [ __ ] in Italian
breakfast that's our joke this is our
vacation well this video is done
subscribe to top 5 unknowns please
they they deserve it they they google
things like this so they can put
together a worthwhile video is their
best checkout cat dirty talking right
the chef Alvarado on Twitter and
Instagram
kettle Barack comedy on Facebook please
but none really please do it she gets
really no benefit to coming on here just
just drew just you guys just you guys
taller that's the most I can offer her
maybe a dollar I'm gonna have a dollar
thanks good do you accept venmo I could
memo you $1 do that and subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell we have a patreon there's a lot of
perks on them rewards are worth it
goodbye